everything happening on the internet
Magnus Carlson born in
1990 it took some time for him before he
discovered the
internet when I was nine I started
playing a bit online in our family we
would have access to the to the computer
we would have that for each for like um
a few hours a week and I would usually
spend those hours playing playing online
my mom would might shut it off but my
father he was he was so eager to to
watch and I remember once my mom and my
sisters went away so it was just my
father and I for for a few days and uh I
would spend hours and hours playing
playing online and my father would watch
and say just don't tell your mother
don't tell your mother there were events
like the 911 attacks for instance and
that was like right when I was in my
computer time of the week and so my
mother said like please shut off you
need to to learn about this and so I was
watching the news for a few minutes and
then I said can I please go back I I
mean I understand the world is burning
down but this is my computer time so
please